- Working for free on your terms
versus getting paid dick to pay
your dues on not
terms, it's not even close.
- [Jewell] Yeah. It's true.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Big City Distance by Markur)
- [Gary] Morning guys.
Morning.
Wait 'til you see.
It was a good tweet.
Morning.
Morning, morning.
What is she doing?
That's what's
running through my mind.
But let's try to
figure that out over
the next 30, 60, 75 days.
- Yeah.
(group chatter)
- [Gary] But here's what I would
say to just triple reinforce
so we're getting it
through the system,
Steve jump in if when
I'm done if you want to
add anything to this.
I'm very, very excited that
I think pushing
through the system
we get a brief and we go
to our version of the 30 second
spot which is a Facebook
commercial and an
influencer marketing
campaign, both by the way,
for that that to me feels as
right as anything we've done
since it's $20,000 a month,
240 you get Twitter pictures,
you get Facebook comment,
like it's the
most scalable, winnable.
It feels very right to me and
I want to continue to push the
organization in that way.
Okay, thanks guys.
Awesome.
("Big City Distance by Markur)
- [Jewell] What I mean by that
is I love trying new things and
I will give my attention to it
100% like right in the moment
and I will kind of dissect that
world, put my brainpower into it
and then I kind of
move on to the next thing.
'Cause it's like,
okay, something new.
Squirrel almost in a sense.
- Are you able to,
so I think I'm like that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- But what I think
has made me successful is
I've always had one big pillar.
It's kind of like eating
a burger but always having
different complements to it.
- [Jewell] Right.
- I think a lot of people just
eat the potato or the pickle or
the onion or the mayonnaise or
the mayonnaise and mayo or the
ketchup or the jalapeño but
they never eat the burger.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Like I have the burger,
Wine Library,--
- [Jewell] Yep.
- VaynerMedia,--
- my personal brand.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and this
episode 241 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Investing, those are my burgers.
But I do a million things.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Do you know how
many people think this,
he's covering me for
this, this is insane.
I have no time.
- [Jewell] Yeah, exactly.
- For me to spending 49 minutes
on this is so fucking crazy.
- [Jewell] It is.
- It makes zero
sense but it sits in
the GaryVee brand pillar.
I believe in it but
it is me being ADD'd out.
- [Jewell] Yes.
- What I think you
need to figure out is,
you got to create
at least one burger.
I've got four, right?
You need to have one.
- [Jewell] Yes.
- If you feel you don't
and I don't know yet but
that's the analogy.
- [Jewell] Yeah so I would say
I don't necessarily
have a burger.
- [Gary] Right.
Because what the burger does is
allow you to create the wealth
creation or the
financial stability--
- [Jewell] Exactly.
- that allows you to go flirt.
I don't think people realize is
by documenting and communicating
on a daily basis as you build an
audience that is just interested
in people, reality TV at scale,
it opens up business
development opportunities.
You never know when you're gonna
write something or say something
in a video six years from now
that unlocks the leader that
wants to see you.
I had one of the great stars of
the last 20 years here came in
here a couple hours ago,
they came to me off
the documenting and creating.
And people
think I'm pulling off,
I'm not pulling it off.
I'm leaving millions of dollars
on the table each year
by being me.
Now, I'm getting
some too but it's a real,
unless you work for yourself and
you're playing in the longest game
of all time,
it's not recommended.
- [Deon] But even
that approach though,
the long game.
Once I turn that
on in my mind,--
- [Gary] Changes everything.
- everything,
everything changes.
With Diddy,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- film director,
social media stuff,
using a lot of
your strategies to help
him and he's trying to
go reach a new audience.
- [Gary] Yeah.
It's time for him.
And this is as much for you
as it is for everybody who's
watching 'cause I think
this is a new thought I have.
I think there's
a lot of DRocks,
like I think a lot of people see
DRock and they know I pay him
and they're like well
shit, I can't do that.
I have to do this.
- [Jewell] Yes.
- I actually
don't think that's true.
I actually think there are
thousands of people that are
watching this right now and
even if you didn't have the
serendipity and the luck of
being here and naturally come to
you in the comments of
DailyVee, you're gonna get this.
I think that there's just
like, if I were you and more
importantly the 10,000 people
watching right now for this
advice, they
should go to YouTube.
They should spend
a month find 5900,
437 people making video content
who have very few subscriptions.
DRock could have been had.
Somebody could have emailed
him and said I believe in your
talent, come and be my partner.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Come and document me.
I'm gonna be like that.
Believe in me.
I think you can
sell people on that
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- I would believe you.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Let alone 500 people that want
to be artists and who just want
to do it and who
want to be nomads too.
So that's another
thing to think about, man.
If you can't afford
it I just genuinely,
you have to understand
it's a supply and demand game.
- [Jewell] Right.
- When people get mad
about working for free,
they don't understand
it's all supply and demand.
No hard-core amazing computer
developer works for free any
more 'cause there's a demand.
- [Jewell] Right.
- When there are
unlimited kids filming,
listen, if you're
Steven Spielberg, go.
But before you're that,
where do you think,
you know it's so funny.
Working for free, working
for free on your terms versus
getting paid dick to
pay your dues on not terms,
it's not even close.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
(group crosstalk)
- [Gary] You mean this?
(DRock laughs)
When DRock does Casey.
- [Jewell] Love all.
- [Gary] It's fun, right?
'Sup my man?
- Farokh, it's nice to meet you.
- How are you?
My pleasure, sit.
- Very good.
Thanks very much.
Branding, marketing, social
media services and all that
stuff so it's getting
really hard to maintain
both and balance.
Both from a...
So, I'm--
- Mr. Good Life.
- [Farokh] Yep,
Mr. Good Life is my main page,
it's my public figure one for a
million verified luxury page
(inaudible) so that's where
I grew most of my money.
(inaudible) luxury
world so like--
- Listen, I think you're
in a great place, right?
Instagram is what
I care about right now.
You're in a space
that I care about.
We're doing a ton of
influencer marketing.
I think that this is exactly
why doing the right
thing is the right thing.
You know, there's a billion
people that are emailing us
everyday to meet with me.
I'm not even meeting with
you for kicks and giggles.
I'm not meeting with
you 'cause you're handsome.
I'm meeting you 'cause you've
done something right in a space
that I care about.
- 'Sup brother?
- [Gary] Good to see you, bro.
- There he is, man.
James, nice to meet you.
- [Gary] James, how are you?
Love your fucking--
- [James] Thanks, man.
- [Gary] This is a fox,
fucking awesome.
You just have to
be mentally prepared,
like right now you should be
building your business to pay
20% vig to the platform.
Now, what you can also do,
depending upon what your
strategy is is start building
outside of the platform.
There's two moves.
You're more, it's more important
that you're just not at the
fucking mercy of Instagram.
- [Man] Right.
- Instagram and Facebook are the
beasts of the world but I don't
know, look, look what
happened with Snapchat.
Who the fuck knows? VR?
You just never want
to be at the mercy of,
everybody who's ever been at
the mercy of being organic SEM,
first result on Google or email
or you just never want to be at
the mercy of anything.
Shit's about to hit the fan and
I think it's gonna happen this
year so this is
the right time to move.
- [Farokh] That's exactly
what I told myself yesterday.
- This is the
right time to move.
$80 billion into
television commercials.
Where do you think
that money's going?
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's going to you.
So I think the question becomes
what business do
you want to build?
Awesome. Good to
see you again, man.
How are you, my man?
- How you doing?
- Real pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- Jacob.
- How are you?
Jacob, how are you?
Real pleasure.
How you guys doing?
- Very good, very good.
- [Gary] Good.
Thanks for coming in.
Tell me about your world.
- [Greg] Yeah, I just recently
in the last three and a half,
four years I've just
been involved in the
whole social media world.
Kind of (inaudible)
to be an influencer,
have a acting background.
Born and raised in Florida,
moved to L.A.
when I was 17 to chase the whole
dream of becoming an actor.
YouTube--
- Yep.
- [Greg] and I saw that,
you're an influencer yourself.
- Yep.
- [Greg] So it's like, you hear
the term a lot a coach's player.
Coaches are the
ones that play the game.
- Yes.
- [Greg] So they know how
to direct the players the best.
- [Gary] Yes,
that's a good analogy.
- And if you're
an influencer who,
you know, monopolizes on that,
became an entrepreneur,
this, that,
et cetera, et cetera.
- [Gary] Yep.
- You understand--
- [Gary] Very much.
- when you see it, when you're
from an early stage,
when you know
you've kind of tapped--
- [Gary] It's funny,
I had Rudy, Nicholas,
Jerome, Brittany, all of them
and I said none of you
know what's
gonna happen in a year.
And they were
like so funny about it.
And it was 'cause I lived it
with YouTube and Twitter
the generations before.
I get it.
For sure, that
makes a lot of sense.
So if I was like
your brother and partner,
I'd be like, "Man, listen to me,
you know how I've been right
"since we were kids
about where the world's going?
"Let's write a TV show,
let's do it on Facebook,
"and let's stay the course."
So I don't want CAA or
Propogate or Endemol to
have control over you.
- [Greg] Right.
- You actually
have a lot of leverage.
- [Greg] Right.
- So the question becomes
how do you underwrite it?
So as long as you can
sell a brand or an investor,
you're good.
- [Greg] Yeah.
- And then you
just got to be patient.
You've lived it.
You've lived building more fame
in that world that has parlayed
into, you know,
they play together.
- [Greg] Right, right.
- You can be
agnostic and in your world,
you have leverage.
- [Greg] Yeah.
- And in the
other world, you don't.
- [Greg] Right.
- So for me it's like quadruple
down on the leverage to get you
maybe, you know?
You know this man?
- Do you know this man?
- You better know.
(Gary laughs)
Co-sign me Gary.
- Co-signed.
- Co-signed, check.
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
- Hi. I'm Brittany.
- Such a pleasure, Britt.
- Anthony.
- [Gary] Anthony,
how are you, man?
- Good.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- I was curious, social media
influencers and influencers in
general, where do you see
that going this year and three,
four years down the line?
Are brands utilizing them more?
- [Gary] Yes.
- Okay.
- [Gary] But, it's a
supply and demand issue.
There'll be more money in,
there'll be more competition.
- [Anthony] Yeah.
- So, it's a marketplace.
So, it's gonna be a really
competitive marketplace but it's
gonna be a huge marketplace.
- Okay.
- [Gary] So, Google Adwords.
The people that
were winning in 2001,
'02 and '03 when I would give
them the advice that more people
were coming, they got scared.
But I'm like, no,
no, you don't get it.
It's gonna go from a
$100 million market to a
$4 billion market and as
long as you're good,
as long as you guys
keep crushing your content,
you'll be fine.
- [Anthony] Yeah.
- It's the people
that are in early.
So it's like buying
beachfront property and
building a shitty house.
Like will that be worth as much?
You're still on
the beach, right?
So it's still worth money but
your neighbor built a much nicer
house so that
will go for $8 million,
your's will go for
$4 million. Got it?
- That's right.
- [Gary] Alright.
- [Anthony and Gary] Cool.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for coming,
congrats on everything.
- [Brittany] Nice to meet you.
- Ping me anytime.
- [Gary] Which one, brother?
- [Phil] Where we do
the investing and buying and
creating brand and
building off of influencers.
- [Gary] Let's go through
all the seven figure stuff,
vet it all, okay?
- [Phil] Okay.
- Alright, let me know.
- [Phil] See ya.
- [Gary] See ya later.
See ya tomorrow.
10:09 at night, trying to find
my drinks meeting right now.
Texting Tyler and
my friend Constantine.
A little meeting,
a little business meeting.
He says he's here.
I don't see him.
Good day, busy, huh?
Today was intense.
Hey ya, brother.
- Sorry, man.
- [Gary] No worries.
How's everything at home?
- Everything's great.
- Crazy, right?
- Oh, it's ins--
("Sideways" by MadReal)
- [Tiffany] What's your
main piece of advice, overall?
Regardless if
someone's in social media,
they're trying to
start their own business.
- [Gary] Reverse
engineer your truth.
It's all self-awareness and
then putting yourself in
a position to succeed.
Too many people wish
they're something instead of
realizing what they are.
So less dreaming more
practicality but more dreaming
in the context of
practicality. Right?
So you don't have to be the
prettiest or the smartest or the
best at tech or the best singer,
it's about understanding.
I was an entrepreneur always.
I didn't know that social media
was gonna come along and
entrepreneurship was
gonna be cool and people
wanted to take selfies.
I was who I was and
the world came to me.
You can't force
yourself to be an influencer.
yourself to be a fashionista.
You can't force
yourself to be a food critic.
You gotta actually figure out
what you are and what you love
and then go all-in on that
and then they will come to you.
Everybody's trying to go to
where it's going instead of,
you know, then
you're just a flash in the pan.
Love you, pal.
Congrats with
everything at home.
Alright, DRock.
- [DRock] Later.
("Sideways" by MadReal)